QUESTION LIKE THIS IS
"SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING.
I AM SHANNON BREAM IN FOR
BRET BAIER.
CHUCK SCHUMER CALLS IT A GENUINE
BREAKTHROUGH.
WHITE HOUSE SAYS IT ENDS CRISIS
TO CRISIS BUDGETING.
NEW SPENDING DEAL IN THE SENATE
WOULD SHOWER THE PENTAGON AND
DOMESTIC PROGRAMS WITH ALMOST
$300 BILLION ABOVE EXISTING
LIMITS.
WHETHER CONSERVATIVES IN THE
HOUSE WILL GO ALONG WITH IT
REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
AND THEN THERE IS NANCY PELOSI.
MIKE EMANUEL IS ON CAPITOL HILL.
GOOD EVENING.
>> THE DRAMA IS NOT OVER, EVEN
AFTER BIPARTISAN LEADERS IN THE
SENATE ANNOUNCED AGREEMENT ON A
TWO-YEAR BUDGET DEAL.
>> THE COMPROMISE WE HAVE
REACHED WILL ENSURE THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN YEARS OUR ARMED
FORCES WILL HAVE MORE OF THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO KEEP
AMERICA SAFE.